ofrenda este tambor en los instrumentos
más antiguos que me han ido allí tienen
registros
y para la mayor parte de la historia fue
tocado por mujeres mujeres que conectaba
a la comunidad de los hits más la vida
de amor y los nacimientos y las
estaciones
o tambor o más oscura
que por mucho tiempo pues que ha sido y
fue aplastado las mujeres las que tienen
faltado como un directo
cuando vemos a una mujer tocando tambor
la nuestra memoria ancestral volcanes
imágenes la deuda del paleolítico que
frecuentemente era representada tocando
tambores
ah
a
no
la puerta
si no la vas
el corazón
no
muchas artes
dentro d
a
ábrete al encuentro
el puente se ve bien
[Música]
y
lo que yo siento no lo dejes pasar
sentimientos
te invita a soñar
[Música]
en mis pasos temores hasta el día
bien
los bajos récord de récord de recorte
y
sí
[Música]
y esto no lo ve
despacio
bien
sentimientos
mi vida son mías
indicación
mi caso
invita
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]